The fundamental assumptions of Western
civilization are valid.
How about that?
You know,
it's not.
You think it's an accident.
Oh,
here's how you find out,
okay.
Which countries do people want to move
away from?
Hey,
not ours.
Which countries do people want to move
two hours.
Guess what?
They work better and it's not because we
went around the world stealing
everything.
We could get our hands on it because we
got certain fundamental assumptions.
Right?
Thank God for that.
After thousands and thousands of years
of trying and because of that,
we've managed to establish a set of
civilizations that are shining lights in
the world.
You know,
now you can be pretty damn filthy and
still be a shining light in this world,
right?
Because if you look around the world at
the state of governance in most places,
it's like the most pathological corrupt
and vicious thugs rule.
And to stand out as an illuminated light
against that background is it so
difficult?
But nonetheless,
you know,
we're as good as it's gone and unless we
can come up with something better,
we should be very careful about messing
around with that.
So why don't we start with the
assumption that we're doing something
right?
One of the things we're doing right,
for example,
is that we actually value the
individual,
right?
The individual has intrinsic value in
western societies.
Do you know how long it took people to
formulate that as an idea and how
unlikely that ideas that poor you,
you know,
useless,
powerless you with all your damn fault,
you're actually worth something.
You're worth something to the point that
the law has to respect you.
God,
we don't want to abandon that for some
half witted collectivism,
which we're doing as rapidly as possible
because one of the things that
characterizes the radical left types is
they don't give a damn about you as an
individual or about individuals at all.
You're black or you're white or you're
Latino or you're transsexual,
you're homosexual or whatever.
You're a group.
You're a member of a group,
and the only thing that matters is the
group.
Well,
I can tell you if the only thing that
matters is the group,
you bloody well don't matter very much.
And then you've got to ask yourself just
exactly what sort of people are trying
to set things up.
So it is that the individual doesn't
matter very much.
Well,
it's the sort of people to whom the
individual doesn't matter very much and
I might suggest that you don't elect
them and that when they attempt to take
power that you do everything you can to
stop them.